ok les tue l'amour c'est vraiment des
petits détails qui peuvent anéantir un
coup avec une meuf en une demi seconde
alors ya les tue l'amour classique par
exemple tu ramènes un soir une même chez
toi tu rends compte que tu as oublié de
ranger certains éléments ou alors si
tout à coup elle a un peu faim je peux
pas lui donner à manger n'importe quoi
ah bah si tu veux du groupe pâtes et de
moutons ils périment demain on peut le
finir quoi tu n as pas le pâté de
moutons tu fais pitié
il ya un petit peu de tout l'amour qui
est assez incroyable c'est quand tu veux
être sensuel avec une meuf et au lieu de
ça sans faire exprès tu fais totalement
inverse c'est à dire que tu lui fais
totalement mal non mais les filles elles
ont trop de cheveux sa part tout en
parlant de cheveux moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir des cheveux qui lorsque je les
couacs avec un peigne fond cet effet là
la coupe des grands mères tu peux avoir
ce héros chance avec les mof fait comme
moi adopte la coupe de grand mère
[Musique]
résultat garanti du coup je fais partie
de cette catégorie de mecs qui se coiffe
en mettant un bonnet sur la tête ou une
sorte de truc qui aplatit sa part contre
la meuf faut pas qu'elle ne découvre
[Musique]
salut ah non mais ça c'est parce que je
sais pas si c'est pour me coiffer enfin
c'est parce que j'ai les cheveux frisés
et tous les gens ils pensent qu'avoir un
chat c'est trop mignon et que ça te
faire gagner un des points auprès d'une
meuf elle va trouver ça adorable mais on
oublie souvent un petit détail
ah ouais ça c'était mes vacances à la
rochelle on avait fait du deltaplane et
où tu es trop un aventurier ça sent
mauvais là c'est quoi
ah ouais ouais c'est mon chat ça ça
c'est ça sent un peu bas ça pue la merde
oui on peut dire ça ça pue la grosse
crotte bien puante de chats jeu désolé à
moi ça me dérange pas au contraire
j'aime bien
faut aussi que j'arrête de commander un
plat épicé quand je suis au resto avec
une meuf
il ya des mecs quand il mange ultra
épices et ça leur fait rien du tout moi
quand je mange une merguez ça se voie
directe
c'est sûr que ça va là ouais carrément
je pense juste que ça manque un petit
peu de sel
mais voilà c'est là c'est parfait parce
que le corps d'un mec extrêmement musclé
issue un peu pendant l'effort ça peut
être sexy mais un mec qui suit comme un
gros porc parce qu'ils mangent une
merguez
c'est plutôt ridicule bon après faut
aussi que j'arrête de dormir avec un
masque et des boules quiès
c'est autre chose comment ça t'as pas
envie de faire l'amour comme ça la tenue
d'un coup il faut également que j'arrête
de mettre des t-shirt gris faut aussi
que j'arrête d'acheter ce de
déodorant qui te fait une marque de talc
blanche sous l'aisselle city les mecs
qui ont acquis ont inventé ce des eaux
tu sors tout propre de la douche
tout d'un coup des eaux et pendant 24
heures tu es un gros porc avec du talent
que blanc sous les aisselles la nes est
ce que tu peux me sortir trois photos
coop illico s'te plaît tu me fais ça
asap
ouais j'ai changé de haut comment tu
sais enfin le master's tout l'amour
c'est le slip que j'ai depuis que j'ai
14 ans et que je remets seulement quand
j'ai plus de caleçon propre celui au
fond de l'armoire avec des motifs
dégueulasse dessus tu le connais ce slip
je veux dire personnellement en tout cas
ce slip c'est vraiment sympa quand tu as
oublié que tu l'as mis j'ai envie de toi
maintenant et non en fait je vais y
aller
merci d'être aussi nombreuse ma page
facebook norman fait des vidéos en ait
qu'une seule et elle est vraiment sympa
[Musique]
et toi ta tête tu l'amour aussi
j'ai pas de problème
d'accord je comme tout le monde